avec nous l'économiste en chef de
l'industrielle alliance clément gignac
bonsoir soit on sent clément gignac est
avec vous on va parler beaucoup de la
situation pour le canada ce que ça veut
dire pour le canada mais d'abord la
situation semble avoir dramatiquement
changé dans les derniers jours
ok définitivement parce que du côté doit
suivre l'exemple on pensait encore une
semaine que c'était limité la chine
or on voit ces derniers jours que se
maintenait d'eau continent qui sont
affectés d'autres pays maintenant même
les etats unis n'excluent pas de
commencer à voir davantage de cas et
tout savoir avoir de l'impact sur
l'économie mondiale les économies
mondiales est beaucoup plus intérêts que
bloquer lorsqu'on avait eu d'autres
situations comme celle-là donc la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et pleinement
intégré il ya beaucoup plus de touristes
qui font en sorte que l'économie
mondiale
on parle peut-être une croissance
maintenant que près de 2 me de points 6%
au-dessus du toit au point deux qu'on
aurait pu présumé qu'on apprend 2020 ce
qui s'appelle pratiquement une récession
mondiale définitivement pas ce que ça
veut dire que la chine va être à quoi 2
3 % peut-être au premier trimestre
deuxième trimestre est là et la chine
que vous savez c'est pas loin de 7 % du
pib mondial
en europe on côtoie pratiquement la
récession donc la santé publique font
les bonnes choses avec la quarantaine
mais se savent a dit que le secteur des
services restauration divertissement
tout ce qui conduirait voyage ça va très
frappés d'une façon très importante au
premier trimestre alors tourisme et
tourisme et voyages au sens large on va
voir un graphique que vous avez tiré de
la firme moddy's qui nous montre donc
etats-unis/canada malaisie jusqu'au
vietnam l'importance du voyage et du
tourisme dans le pib de chacun de ces
pays et en bleu c'est la part de
touristes chinois
donc le canada est ici la sphère de
touristes chinois est à peu près 10%
on est en fait sion pour l'année 2010 ne
font pas vraiment maintenant les 10% ici
on n'exclut évidemment les voyages à
l'intérieur d'eux
quatre à trans transfrontalier donc
c'est tout ce qui touche au risque qui
est qui qui une nuitée ou plus et là on
voit que maintenant c'est pas loin de
10% que représentent des touristes
chinois pour le canada donc c'est quand
même si le motif
on est d'avis que le canada aurait
commis quinzaine voire peut-être frapper
davantage par le corno virus peau au
niveau santé publique mon plan
économique que l'économie américaine est
ce c'est pas juste sous l'angle du tout
risque on ne peut plus toutes
proportions gardées que les états unis
mais également sur d'autres angles et on
a préparé de quoi également pour
l'illustré notre graphique qui montrent
clairement qu'au niveau du commerce des
ressources et du tourisme
le canada serait touchée si on voit que
on esprits au niveau du tourisme que le
canada la portion des riches chinois est
important mais regardez que le canada
qu'elle met un expo un pays exportateur
de pétrole de ressources naturelles donc
à ce moment là nous on est beaucoup plus
affectée que d'autres pays qui dans le
fond de son pot ou aussi impliqué par
exemple l'arabie saoudite et surtout
chez sur les ressorts il exact mais
moins sur les autres avaient déjà baissé
10 $ gérald depuis un mois où est donc
on voit que ça ça va frapper au niveau
de l'économie canadienne
poté pas autant que la religiosité il va
sans dire puisque c'est un producteur
mondial important mais nous on est
exportateur net avant de frapper et le
commerce parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que si l'économie mondiale des salaires
parce que la chaîne d'approvisionnement
mondiale est affectée à ce moment là
vous allez avoir le canada ou que le
secteur représente 25 à 28% de 9 pb sur
moins de commerce mondial ça va nous
frapper maintenant principal partenaire
c'est les états unis et non pas la chine
dont indirectement ça vient nous
rappeler tout ça si nous sommes touchés
sur les trois grands ronds tourisme et
commerce ressources qu'on est au centre
avec la malaisie
ça veut dire quoi pour l'économie
canadienne en récession là non on
n'irait pas récent mais la mêlée ziv de
même beaucoup plus frappé quelqu'un
d'hommes et gardons l'esprit que s'il a
en fait la bande week end n'est qu'au
dernier 4e trimestre on est en
stagnation pratiquement zéro et parlait
d'une accélération au premier trimestre
de 1 point 3 % du pib
moi j'en doute parce que si on combine
cela
avec le fait que les voies ferrées ont
été quand même fermé pendant plusieurs
jours et le contrairement à la grève du
cn on ne savait pas d' avance que les
voies ferrées tapo être fermées donc les
entrepreneurs et les entreprises ont été
surpris donc probablement que la
croissance sera pas loin de votre très
anémique au premier trimestre donc
effets à moyen terme du coronavirus oui
sur l'économie canadienne et effets à
court terme des blocages vers on estime
peut-être points trois points qu'à
peut-être l'impact sur le pib du mois de
février
donc dans ce sens là on pourra voir une
situation que la banque du canada qui
elle espérait une ré accélération de
l'économie canadienne basée sur ré
accélération de l'économie mondiale des
exportations baissent monstres monstres
qui avait pas cette règle c'est la
ration là et le la semaine prochaine ça
sera intéressant à voir
moi je code d'une porte et gérad 69 75 %
que la banque du canada pourrait décider
d'abaisser son taux directeur dès la
semaine prochaine donc pourquoi parce
que je sais lecture aussi prévisions qui
avaient mis en place le 6 semaines
clairement l'économie mondiale se
stabilise pas au contraire avoir
décéléré et se voit l'impact sur
l'économie canadiens dont peste tôt
possible si c'est viable s'ils voient la
semaine prochaine ce soit dans six
semaines mais clairement l'économie
canadienne aura besoin soit d'un budget
très expansionniste la part d'ottawa ou
sous et les baisses de taux parce que
sinon je pense qu'on va avoir une
situation que la reprise concernant des
vont avoir lieu beaucoup plus tôt au
vent de l'année merci beaucoup clément
gignac qui plaisait